hannover darf luca und ich bin 23 jahre
alt und jule ist hinter der kamera und
ist 84
hier sieht es bereits im titel meine
lieben freunde und zwar rate ich heute
mal wieder alter also das alter von der
lukb also dass jetzt die person ihr seht
die links neben mir eingeblendet ich
würde sagen aufgrund der harfe und auch
der kompletten haut dass er 22 ganz kurz
die erklärung
david eckel klicks ist ein kollege von
mir und dazu verdient er okay ihr seht
auch wieder eingeblendet hier neben mir
ich würde tatsächlich bei ihr sagen
19 ich von erst 23 sagen juli 38 was auf
dem foto sieht man auf jeden fall dass
er bartwuchs hat das heißt er müsste auf
jeden fall älter entwickeln
hast du ein bisschen stoppeln ziemlich
teure fest ich würde sagen dass er 18 20
wenn ich einen heute schaffen sollte er
ist das für mich so wie als wir abends
schon auf dem mond war dass er jetzt
bestimmt 19.40 so scheiße darin ja das
hier ist das nächste mädchen
sie hat auf jeden fall noch eine
zahnspange und man sieht auch auf der
stirn so einen kleinen pickel
das heißt die person ist anscheinend
noch in der pubertät würde ich mal sagen
und ich würde sagen vom alter her 15
ein forderndes jahr als immer wieder den
jungen vielleicht klappt es da ein
bisschen besser also ich würde sagen
dass er auch schon ein bisschen älter
ist die sache ist dass der eu die von
jack & jones gibt keine ahnung aber ich
würde sagen dass man solche sachen
endlich er damals getragen hat von daher
2017 alter egal ich system doch zu
fassen die nächste person
[Musik]
14-18 alter das kann nicht sein
nein doch damit du jetzt auch mal was
reifen kannst dass die nächste person 84
14 frau verdammt richtig laut gefühl mit
feta hatte man ein bisschen besser
geklappt bei dir vielleicht klappt das
ja jetzt auch hier würde ich sagen mit
dem filter 14
das ist wieder einmal gemacht auf meinem
kanal habe ich glaube ich von 20 leuten
viermal erraten können und dies mag ich
bisher null punkte insgesamt erzielen
können wir hier einfach nur zum affen
nächsten person gebe ich den tipp sie
ist noch etwas jünger 24 spaß ruft ich
würde in ihrem fall sagen dass sie 12 9
mein junge für dich 14.11 was endete bin
ich hoffnung oder weil das ist der
letzte junge die nicht haben
13.10 war's das ich dachte ich hochladen
oder auch dies personen sind 16 schon
geschafft
ebenfalls gewesen das musst du jetzt
aber schaffen
mit filter 72 ich glaube das hat auch
wieder zahnspange bezahlung 16
die drittletzte besonders diese hier 14
12 egal ob wenigstens habe ich eine
person schon recht vorletzte nochmal
endspurt also ich bin mir auch hier
wieder überhaupt nicht sicher ich finde
es könnte alles sein zwischen 12 und 18
ich sag mal 17 computer wenigstens die
letzte person jetzt letzte chance
ich sage
jetzt ja leute gehabt wahrscheinlich
gemerkt in diesem video das ich
überhaupt nicht das alter von menschen
einschätzen kann wenn das wie die
allerdings trotzdem gefallen da will ich
mich selbst wenn sie dort über einen
daumen hoch von euch unter dem video
hier freuen und abonniert main kanal
falls noch kein teil der looser
[Musik]